hey I'm back this is the third day in a
row on screaming bullets and I'll have
to make it up somehow to the viewers who
who want instructive chess I might hang
around afterwards to do like Q&A or play
viewers or whatever but right now the
elite bold arena is going on so I
figured I'd get some hopefully higher
quality bullet games in compared to
yesterday at least here we have a London
which is a structure I've had many times
before
9h fives are good move by black
Oh II 5 so soon
I still feel comfortable as whites have
some time advantage ideas of Knight a5
b7 is kind of weak play King D 2
and maybe I'll go for the tray the
bishops mmm wait for him to take
I'll take their what to do
maybe g5 ideas now g5 doesn't work with
f4 could work Hui for is a big weakness
don't play Knight of 6 he played nine f6
yeah this is not a great position let's
neutralize F file he has an IG 3 though
not a great game I need some miracle
here
go after b7 and then maybe get the
Knight to d6
you
not looking so good though bring the
king in
yeah I will take this and then I have
two passers supported by the night um
still not looking so good
just allow me to queen you just allowed
me to queen
I win I'd even realized I was up on time
Wow although mo to man and hello San
Diego I don't know what was going on
there
but I wasn't even looking at time I
watch that replay I guess he was moving
too slowly
so I've won the first two now I'm
playing whoa Luke ah've allows for
maestro 0 plane Alekhine
um I've been playing this for the last
couple of days found it to be a
relatively straightforward bold opening
pretty simple development going for this
EFI break I mean theoretically the
Alekhine's not supposed to be that great
but feel like it's an easy opening to
play c4 is hanging currently did he just
lose material I think he did uh f6 maybe
always play off six this is hanging this
is hanging this is hanging winning
something
uh blocks just hop apiece mm let's play
96 and win his knights okay three out of
three a 22nd place I join late but not
too late I guess I joined maybe 15 min
slates so there's hope to catch up to
the leaders let's play another London
this game
yeah messy Marvin I wa I was intending
to stream more instructive chests and
then I saw the elites bullet arenas on
are going on for the next like hour and
10 minutes uh which
I think I don't know the rules but I
think only players above 2,000 are above
2,200 can play which is fun because
there's chances to t gain a lotta rating
my ratings pretty low right now he just
hang a piece mmm where's my tactic maybe
he didn't hang a piece
- - I wanna do the ship g3 I guess and
then put the knight on d4
if we can trade
I'll take this night's
but first I'll torture him and I'll take
it okay
position slightly imbalanced f5s coming
let's move
put the King on III still want to play I
five let's get the rook in I can trade i
rooks terribly misplaced let's play G
three not-so-pleasant
billing for counter fly on the Kings
side maybe I'll get f6 in his rook can't
do too much damage
I don't think f6 we can h6
watch out for time too ooh that's a fork
okay four out of four
none of that starts three plus zero says
San Diego
I'm not sure what he's referring to good
to see do okay so I have another game
let's play Sicilian the Sicilian maybe
maybe we'll transpose to open yeah okay
this lines by d 5 g 3 random move let's
play h5 t h5 was premature maybe not
though ephors a nice square uh that's
kind of annoying let's move back no play
Bishop c5 hopefully he'll hang g3 oh he
saw it
ok well hopefully a little hang D for D
for check and let's take first do this
I'm going for cheapos but he's not
falling for them
the Castle queenside uh that looks like
a poisoned pawn okay this can't be good
for him and let's play this and then f5
or just went his knight and then maybe
his Bishop is stuck a free bishop
a ton of material now slightly down on
time but doesn't matter this looks like
a note mmm that's a fancy move if he
takes with Queen I have wrote g56 with
pawn I have check and now I just went to
clean
okay mate should be somewhere there's
mates
to tournaments although you Civic I'm
doing well
I know San Diego you would like to see
me play longer games I'm gonna try and
stick around after the tournament for a
little bit to do some either longer
games or Q&A or play with viewers so but
right now I want to get my bullet rating
back up just so I feel better about
myself and then I'll do some other
things
taking on g3 so early
let's take there in Queen a3 I've had
this sort of structure a lot recently
let's take with the e pawn I'll play 95
oh he wants to prevent it I'll play it
anyway and he can't castle because my
Queens on a3 I'll put my knight on d4
ah that's a venomous move things are
going to get sharp now
we castles queenside
Queeny seven maybe
rook t7 I can't take him I probably not
I just want to disturb him it's
difficult though Queen take F 2 is
coming I'll play rook to you rip d2 hung
a rook no don't take it
oh he took it oh that's so bad
while I was thinking there well as we've
seen before miracles do happen
[Music]
hoping for a miracle here it's playoff
for solid I don't want to trade Queens
but I guess I'm not trading Queens uh
he's doing stuff my Rick's defended by
my queen so that's a slight miracle and
I can take with check
and maybe I keep checking him and then
put the Queen back on before
keep checking him cream of queen before
a four attacked the pinned pawn mmm
still not looking great I like cream of
stuff
no okay yeah the skewer
[Music]
just fling pawns this is not promising
at all
maybe he'll still meet me uh he checked
me to me okay I lost again I'm in a
loving place that was brutal
yeah I still need to break 2400
I have to ask suss every time I was
migrans I assumed grams means grandma
unless you're talking about like the
measurement grams of something no my
grandma's doing well I'll see her
tomorrow I have to like fix her computer
and her phone and her Alexa device but
doing very well uh he five I want to
play let's do this first
in cattle any five maybe four coming
clean these six keep initiative
keeping initiative
ooh tricky move Bishop a4 maybe what do
I do here
calculating
I don't know let's not waste too much
time I mean I still like my position
six maybe my positions nothing special
but trying to make it special
and put the ricany cheats maybe going
for some attacking ideas
it's calculating night 85 this should
take you four I didn't see that
mmm I can take here okay it's going to
get messy again
take on d5 was something maybe months
wuji threes week he has to play in 92 or
not h 5 g 4 is coming but with the night
f 4 mm let's play a 5 pawn storm and
then move move away
okay that's a free night
let's do this and this and this
you
you
ah I'm just taking everything yeah I
flagged him okay I'm trying to get my
rating points back from yesterday
okay
so so far I've only lost one game I'll
play a scandi which now has transposed
into some weird opening should be
somewhat preferable for black I'm kind
of like reversed Kings immune structure
uh I believe um upon let's make things
interesting III is week three falls can
I take this this is interesting this is
really interesting and I left two is
coming and then I think I win the rook
somehow yeah and this King is still
exposed my knight should not get trapped
immediate will be I don't know let's
play this ah he checked me
hey this is hanging I think but that's
hanging so many things are hanging
should be for coming g5 and then missus
hanging
and I should be mating him where's my
mate
maybe this
or
team mates
it's very close so I'm a pawn storm
let's play this
you just seemed stuck
to next
I think I'm threatening mates
just positional chess he's attacking
upon defend you have to watch out for
time it's a skewer and it's a free pawn
destructors king when the bishop
you
okay there we go that was nice
pogchamp one two three good to see you
thanks for the comments a leap ugh is
this your first time watching leap ugh
you missed my stream last month I was
streaming with an actual pug I think it
should be on YouTube though
Lucas
he takes his donation back because I
play this candy I mean it wasn't a truce
candy because my opponent didn't take on
g5 but feel free like if you want to see
a certain opening or if you don't want
to see a certain opening let me know in
the chats let's play Knight c4
to take and then this is very common we
see sixes of targets
I can't really exploit it too soon I
should keep things defended
and the idea for a white is not to trade
anything I'm gonna play Bishop t2 and
black suffers because he's low in space
and all the minor pieces are still on
the board now I have to trade but it's
still Pleasant c6 is still weak making
the night there
um a six is a week maybe I'm winning I'm
winning upon lots of things were
attacked there
like Queenie to and go after a six also
d6 is a week maybe I play f4 oh I didn't
see that well there goes my advantage
maybe five gonna be a fight
work off the diagonal
it's play rook a3 oh the bishop hangs no
why am i hanging everything
okay this is ugly I have a slight time
advantage I have to go for the flag a
dirty flag ah let's take this
hmm but the rockin c6
Rippon still slight time advantage it's
going to be close so
don't checkmate me
you
don't make me
No Oh
you
I'm tricky move very tricky move okay
that was kind of dirty the plug is
asking for a king's indian more London
and Carol con games please semi sob says
San Diego okay I'm trying my best to
keep all these in mind was there a white
opening suggested I guess London oh I'm
playing Pesce Pasha is also streaming
trivia Pesce cocktail ah yaha - egrets
shot Matisse - boy that's all the
Russian I know I wonder is he streaming
in Russian or English
toshka is a great streamer this is a
time where multi twitch would be pretty
pretty interesting uh is that uh that's
um he's gonna play f5 it's a good move
do this the night away
maybe g4g fors kind of explosive before
a very typical London idea when the file
is opened the bishop wants to coming to
play and f3 a three gets forked though
ooh
d4 hangs No
dasvidaniya pika
okay lots of Knights are attacked f3 is
coming also h7 is a meeting square and
there's x-ray vision against his queen
and he's thinking a long time oh he's
streaming on YouTube interesting
did he just calculate some force mates
okay I have to survive this somehow
Queen b6 coming within King takes c3 I
have no idea what's going on Yanni
Pawnee my achok mighty
but is night okay his mine and rook are
hanging I can just take this right
don't checkmate me my p5 doesn't do
anything I'm happy to sack back a piece
this is really scary but his queen is
currently attacked twice so this is okay
that's a free queen I'm just up a ton of
material and up a ton of time and
checkmate is coming good game ah - oh
you say game party though
uh I may have been my first time playing
what's-his-name pesca
so now I'm in sixth place Aldous 64 I
wonder if he's related to Cruz 64
some stiff competition oh I'm playing
him uh let's play chess
oh he's so tricky he wants a French I
guess it's gonna be some read French
I don't usually play this stuff but I
guess I have to just play chess it
should be five is kind of scary 95 is
also scary this is bad
Queen d5 maybe
and then queen her let's play this oh my
gosh what is he doing okay
I maybe I'm surviving this I have two
pieces for a rook and two pawns I can
maybe take that and then try and cocoon
mmm okay I'm alive but the night back on
g6
maybe King King should not go to g7 play
metaphor aggressive move
maybe c6 and Queen d5
his HP ponds gonna be really annoying
and that doesn't work either let's play
c5 we dry for him I might fork him
that's a fork this ruckus attacked and
his queen I don't think he saw that
because he's thinking I'm still down on
time though hmm
maybe check and rook here he's gonna
play a three and then I play here
attacking the rook in the H pawn he'll
play rook h1 oh my gosh I have a hyung
mate
No how did that happen annoying H pawn
good game he played well I thought I was
coming back and then he mated me chess
player is 18 hey I'm 24 20 it's nice
what someone wanted a caro-kann I forgot
who wanted the caro-kann we're going to
see a caro-kann I don't usually play the
caro-kann I really have no idea how to
play this opening especially like the
theoretical line let's play 96 it's an
interesting move maybe night before
ideas Bishop f3 what Bishop b4 f3 is
trouble so now the argument is that he's
overextended and maybe he's too
overextended f5
what are these moves I can take that
east 6 what I can take that as well wait
a minute he wants to destroy me maybe
I'll just suck a piece that's easier and
then if he plays Bishop d3 I have this
otherwise I take here and I have the
initiative mmm
Queen e6 check
I should probably not have allowed that
now we both have ugly pollen structure
except he has an extra piece at age five
preventing King g3
maybe I'll go for this move mmm still
down a piece
neither four is coming I have to make
use of the pieces that I have start
taking pawns
oh that pong is hanging still hanging
maybe
it's still hanging and then we're
trading our lots I have not lost a
single pawn how is that possible
oh my gosh I'm down so much time though
this is bad
and I hung a knight oh yeah yeah okay I
have to start taking stuff
pree moving a lot king power
who teaches a major threats he stopped
it
No
no Knights are so annoying
still meet me please ah that was a
really messy game I apologize to whoever
recommended the caro-kann I completely
botched the opening I was an interesting
position though I'm still above 2400 I'm
in 11th place we have another London
bread-and-butter opening maybe up g3
I don't know why so many people play
this way this is supposed to be pleasant
for for whites
95 Lucas just subscribed Thank You Lucas
I want to play G Phi of a mist let's
take and then play g5
nice I can take and then take care and
oh I mean to pre move that maybe I did I
don't know
well now it's a position
[Music]
okay somehow things kind of liquidated a
white should be better
his twin my pawn back I'll be up a pond
and I have a knight versus a bishop as
Kings called off oh that was a good move
by him I can do mmm do I do
counter-attack yeah when in doubt
counter-attack and then Ricky to his
King will still be cut off should be a
technical win maybe work here if he
allows does not allow
I can do this
some kind of Lucena position
on a mental endgame bring the rook back
me this ooh that was kind of annoying so
very strong move by him I just pushed
the pawn and hope it works I have to cut
the King off
wait I'm down on time too this is bad
but I win this pawn that's nice
rook is super passive I was not a good
decision by him
there you go lather check me time
whoo okay hello the Bali on 24
thanks for watching nirvan Raymond is
back hello
thanks guys for or some supports I made
it back into the top ten
um I'm very far away from first place
Elda 64 is a good player
I have to try and catch up 48 minutes
left in the tournament let's play some
perk I don't know what this is I'm gonna
play a bit more aggressively than normal
let's play ninety to bring the night
here that's kind of annoying still put
the night on our five though I know what
this position is Bishop III who can I
take with night this is going to get
interesting I mean be five in some
positions and might see seven ideas
or just winning everything
this is nice
I can check the cute move and then when
the rook
when the other rook when the bishop whoa
cut the King off
push the pawn touchdown okay
this is over good game he just blender
that this nine of six move
okay I'm still in eighth place back on a
streak 24:22
the goal is to pass King crusher if I
win one more game oh I'm playing King
crusher this is gonna be exciting he's
gonna play this f4 line he played this
other day and good things happened
Queeny to check we had like this exact
line the other day and now he's playing
a bit differently maybe I'll give back
up on maybe I shouldn't though let's
play Czech provokes III I was Bishop is
slightly more sad
maybe the ship okay not Bishop f5 ideas
uh six ideas well let's just queenside
castle be safe I'm up to pawns currently
so now I'm up one pawn rook e8 open file
let's do this
this
so played before maybe this okay his
nights in trouble maybe
what's going on here
to the smooth tech the bishop his night
his position is a bit fragile Bishop III
ideas intake and then this
five maybe and then rookie two ideas to
get some activity here play b6 defend
everything luftwaffe so ambitious my
bishop is sort of awkward but I think
everything is okay everything defends
everything he's debating whether or not
to take on a5 I might want to just take
on B to completely destroy the King
let's do that I don't know if it's good
though
um Queen d2 maybe 54 maybe not so
impressive I'm going on time too
he's a long time what's going on
have to activate my inner Andrew ting ah
no he's mates me no was that forced me
that was forced
no it wasn't forced me I had to play
King b7 good game Kings crusher nirvan
Raymond has to go to terrible things
just happened like at the same moment I
lost a king crusher and nirvan Raymond
is leaving but it's okay berserk is here
berserk one I'm still top 10 but the
goal is to patch past King crusher those
are really painful loss here we have
another London remind me again what
openings I should play because I am
taking opening recommendations let's
take that pawn I think that's a free
pawn it's another free pawn it's another
free pawn
everything in life is free mm II five
glasses
on a move so I can take this
this bishops gonna be stuck rook t5
coming I have a bunch of pawns in a rook
and a knight for the Queen
that's enough material
mm-mean be for sledge III fianchetto or
not Brook T - I have to kind of
consolidate and develop
this is awkward
you
Bishop t2
so you really want to take on a - I'll
allow it
don't know what's going on here
- if necessary
I just want to meet him honey Yates can
I take
maybe not
maybe here
you
you
this is a weird position but I
works for a queen he's a long time
[Music]
I still want a back rank meet him we
listen this
the kanji for
so that's a check nice you just flung
his queen and mate in one move that was
nice
Kings gambit and a Dutch and a semi-soft
okay and a scotch
axe failure always requesting the Scotch
I'll see what I can do it depends what
color I am
still in eighth place still need to pass
king crusher
Gannicus semi Slav yes any Slav no I
mouse slipped d6
okay we have a King's Indian I apologize
San Diego my fault I don't even know
Kings Indian at all I just note to pawn
storm so I'm gonna keep on storming
bring the knight back to f6 this is such
a stressful opening to play
I'm so stressed
say loser rook but I have to destroy him
on the kingside maybe I play this smooth
before could hang in some lines
mmm this is so stressful
and then I teach for uh he just tricked
me
I lose a queen I don't know why people
play the Kings Indian unpleasant opening
I still have night so the rule is you
should never resign when you have nights
things are falling apart really quickly
here
I'll blame it on the mouse lip yeah I
resign that was really bad I should
learn some Kings Indian theory I feel
like not Kings Indian players should
play the Kings Indian just to improve
their overall game okay let's try and
play King's gambit or a scotch okay
we'll play oh we don't have a scotch
well maybe a four-night scotch there we
go
in honor of ox villager what is bishop
before I don't even know what this move
is Bishop D let's just take upon
I think I've seen this before
f-five that can't be good
d5 that's probably a good move taketake
it will play Bishop III this is a
long-term target must d4 is maybe scary
well now I can I don't want to take
let's play this this night is so strong
let's play F no f3 doesn't work now I
want to play off three that was a good
move it was a really good move
quality of play just dropped really low
I'm so long time oh my gosh I'm sorry ex
villager 4 completely botching or
opening
maybe I'm still alive though I'll sack
the exchange
doesn't take it all player of g3 yes
okay I'm alive here actually maybe
there's hope to come back c4 was a
terrible move but he didn't take the
pawn he sucks maybe coming or that
the rock on the open file
you
I'm trying my best I have two ponds this
try and meet him I made it him how did
that happen he was trying to flag me but
he didn't see the main threats okay that
game it's gets devoted to axe villager
for suggesting the Scotch
okay I don't feel good about that I'll
take it
let's play a semi Slav and let's not now
slip semi Slav okay now it's a qgg
exchange radiation this is okay
don't think I mind this Queen c7 maybe a
six typical move not
Bishop's many for typical bring the
Queen somewhere in more useful
keeping my bishop
okay now maybe maybe it's time to try an
attack
you
hmm never know when to attack and when
to play positionally I just hung upon
unfortunate I'm still trying to tak H 4
H 5 H 5 H 4 it's not trade Queens
I guess I have to trade Queens okay
positional chess time
face now I have a three-on-two majority
here's a four-on-two majority but my
majority looks nicer
I haven't square on d3 for the night
let's play g5 preventing metaphor and f6
okay this is seemingly just falling
apart
somehow I'm so alive maybe g4 and night
f2 mates be prevented that
mmm King e6 I guess
he's gonna sack No
bring the night to to be three he lets
me maybe not
this is annoying
[Music]
you just wanna rook I know pawns are
falling to pre-move stuff
you
hey I won that how do I win that I was
down upon most of the game that was nice
Koosh ekeus Keshe Casa is saying I
didn't have to trade Queens I could have
taken a free rook on d1
but the Queen was on I thought the Queen
was on g4
oh man I'll I'll trust you that I just
missed something I'm playing Gannicus
again maybe I'll play a London yep I'm
definitely playing a London maybe he'll
fall for this this Austrian trap he fell
for the Austrian trap this is whether
Irina crushed fell for in the US Women's
Championship she didn't walk into this
Knight g5 line but it's very unpleasant
for for the black side now it's just
winning for white
it's just trade let's not embarrass
myself well say I can convert this
let's do this maybe this can take Annie
for I guess just keep trading stuff by
pressure we now five
I just want to invade also this is a
threat
how do i invade further your fd1
centralized queen doesn't have too many
square is actually I guess I can take
take here
I win this pawn I think there's no
there's no rook moose
mmm murky seven stew I just have to
avoid like cheap tricks now it should be
winning there we go that was nice
it's why you should know opening traps
okay now I need revenge on King crusher
let's play symmetrical you see how many
times I can copy him but I didn't mean
to play this at the e7
so I stopped copying him but this is a
decent position
coming
he likes to sack pawns for some reason
so she could have taken on b5 there
mmm let's do this and attack this I
probably don't want to castle that way
oh I mouse slipped castling I pre moved
mouse slipped
oh that's annoying let's play this to
keep the C file closed Oh work C ones
coming this is not gonna be pleasant
this is not pleasant at all this pawn is
kind of hanging maybe he'll forget about
it he forgot about it
okay now it's a fight
I don't know which king is less safe
mmm let's trade Queens
or not oh that was tricky
well done I'm still sort of alive
this is bad
we some defining stuff
d6 defend everything
and he's long time maybe I can flag him
mmm good move
what to do
okay
pree moving
you
hey I flagged him yes that's revenge for
beating me earlier and I passed him in
the standings life is good
okay sixth place am i within range I'm
within range of top three I guess it's
going to be hard to catch up to Alda
Oxshott Chandra in second place L don't
know hello thousand three
I forgot about the checks all those a
jar hello circle us algorithmic good to
see you Taurus 42 now I'm plant and
playing this land sky play someone
suggested Kings gambit earlier I guess I
won't play this game I'll play whatever
this is play this line
knows what he's doing
but I know what I'm doing
each three preventing the chief or I
guess I have to take this lassie to Zeke
aull we have to play c3
yeah this is okay
yes for Center pons it's a lot of center
pons but as nice on each six maybe I can
play b3 activate the Bishop f3 my knight
is trapped
how is my knight trapped that's annoying
[Music]
let's give him triple pawns
this is a weird position
hang on
Oh taking pawns
I do have to flag him somehow ooh that's
Aryan pleasance his weaknesses
[Music]
the move is such a move
but now I'm up a queen he just has so
many pawns though is really unpleasant
counterplay somehow
mm-hmm confusing position actually this
Bishop's gonna end up being pinned he's
gonna think all or take all his time
here and maybe flag that was a good move
though
hmm maybe this offend
to do this
oh dear this is really bad when g4 I
thought I was up on time earlier
you
you
50 move roll please
you
Oh
does Lee chest like auto claim 15 move
roll I think it does but we were nowhere
close I guess
what's your favorite time control among
every possible um
let's good question I don't think I have
a favorite I mean I do enjoy playing one
minutes as games end quickly so but I
don't know I like I say I don't like the
like classical ninety plus thirty with
like the sudden death extra half-hour I
mean those games they're higher quality
but they it takes so much energy I do
like rapid chess in ten minutes but not
too many tournaments out of those types
of time controls
I guess we're trading in just some
really boring work ending where black
kind of wants to minority attack I don't
know what white wants to do I guess I
just kind of have to wait make sure he
can't play h4 maybe I'll double up on me
file
think you can play maybe I'll put it
rook on b3 actually
ooh interesting
[Music]
these are going to get really
interesting here I get the a file
maybe I invade
I'm going to play before maybe or not
but reckon before
you
you
just dancing around a little bit
I'm looking for a potential breakthrough
interesting
now he just hang a truck he just swung a
rook
now it's interesting for me try and meet
him
oops I had made in one there too bad
made in one okay that's a close call
with the time situation who thinks cool
guy 2189 just subscribed for three
months in a row yeah shoutouts a cool
guy
uh what is this opening oh I'm playing
Elda okay I can't think late b5 yes okay
I trapped him but this is far from over
he's moving really quickly
let's do this
three week
what is this I guess I can take
that was hanging but he didn't see it
I just want to trade everything and be
up upon
easier said than done d3 is still weak
the c6 coming
slightly unpleasant 93 is still
happening a queen g4 check shouldn't be
an issue but maybe it is
it's a scary I mean his still forked
these rooks have been hanging for a long
time but I have my own problems on low
on time
what does that move I'm just gonna trade
everything says pieces were scary well
he can't take on a five oops oh I didn't
mean to pre move that well I got my wish
I said earlier I wanted to trade
everything and beat up upon I've traded
most things
so I'll have to trade more things let's
play h6
check maybe this and play Bishop f1 made
more things he doesn't want to trade
scary position
I'm attacking stuff I win another pawn
and it's not hang anything
there we go winning more things
you
you
remove stuff
three seconds left there we go
hand was shaking towards the end there
I beat Alda finally it was in first
place he's still in first place hey I'm
about to break 2500 currently in 6th
place still lots of people ahead of me
not as many people as before King
crusher again he's plays III this time
what do I want to play maybe some let's
play a reverse London actually could be
relatively simple to play
you
[Music]
mp2 that he's playing aggressively play
Bishop here the bishop on e4 that was a
good move
mmm to tick
I just have to play around his really
annoying Bishop think it's kind of
working
he just sucks stuff but not really and
take care I'm gonna be down a lot of
pawns usually he's the one down a lot of
pawns but now I'm down a lot of pawns
this is bad he doesn't want to trade ok
keep the files closed
maybe I can try and trade Queens
he's being really annoying its pitch oh
I wanted to play h5 there
I have to live with it
hmm
what to do maybe this
really looking bad still sort of alive
we finally trade Queens now let's play
h5 and giving away the night
don't make me hey I got my king in maybe
I can make him this is weird this is
really weird
King f1 and rook f king me to rock f1 is
almost mate I still want to meet him
I'd say that every day about King
crusher let's do this
hey I flagged him nothing brings me more
joy than Fagin King crusher in a dead
losing position it makes me feel
slightly bad but very joyful now I'm
playing Alda again tru64 his brother
what do I want to play let's play c5 go
for this weird line
you
it's kind of weird
complain Bishop e6 here
take and then let's bring the knight
back to c5 we have some position which
resembles some sort of like Alekhine
imma give myself bad pawn structure but
at least my king is safe h5 maybe put
the knight on e4 and play by five or not
to move back before is coming that's not
gonna be pleasant but he didn't play us
that was maybe a mouse let maybe not I
have to double up on the e-file except
he's gonna take over the file
what does night G 5 guess there is a pin
mmm this is scary let's bring the King
back
Takas pawn tack the pawn again my knight
is kind of gonna be stuck in his
territory I have to bring it to be four
so now it's not stuck and I can dance
around a little bit doing well with time
that was an interesting move maybe I can
play this and get a pass H pawn as my
king while his King is within range too
[Music]
okay I win the pawn oh he's winning that
pawn but I win this pawn what's going on
I can't take that yet I have to defend
do this mmm Stu that
no I lost a night
you
No I need a miracle
ooh queenís would be cellmates ah he saw
it a lot of people would would promote
to queen and miss position
but okay good game Alda
guess we're going back and forth
I'm still in sixth place I've been in
sixth place for a while but now I'm Way
ahead of King crusher who's not even in
top ten 18 minutes left I am gonna try
and stick around afterwards give back to
the viewers some Sun way let's play III
play this line
interesting position this might be
hanging he didn't take it
can I sack somehow take take
this looks too fun to pass up actually
it's just winning cuz I fork his Queen
and his Bishop and the e-file opens so
Queenie sevens I just take and his queen
is pinned oh but my knight gets trapped
that's kind of sad
I guess Bishop e5 if I do lose a piece
didn't think that far ahead
ah for I guess yeah why not
okay I'm down a piece I have some
compensation b5 is weak put the rook on
d4 his knight has a hard time getting
back into the game
never mind but d-file is still attacked
three times now I win the pawn now I
have three pawns for the piece
I mean d3 maybe the control the the only
open file on the board
oh he's being tricky and it's paying off
for him let's play a 4 mm it's really
paying off her and g6 is hanging though
kind of but we're trading Queens mmm
this is not intended okay
I need a miracle I need to push pawns
I really need to push pawns ooh I'm
pushing pawns
baby yes
skewer skewer odom I take a queen
I flagged him with 0.15 seconds left yes
okay wasn't I just losing that game I
was down a piece and he was queening his
pawns but that's the power of pushing
pots oops
I did not want to do that okay glocken
a chest patron let's play e4 I still
need to play at Kings gambit I guess
will not happen play a to Knights attack
maybe hold hang mates narrow he doesn't
I'll play the sign I don't think you can
take on c2 because I would trap it let's
play this maybe g3 this is a relatively
Pleasant position even though he wants
to attack me
now it's going to be a really sharp
position
not trying it isn't see its side
I have some attack this looks very
pleasant maybe Queen here
h6g for maybe does that work
better work
or maybe even h 5 h 5 looks fun
ooh five could be played I feel about
that
this this is gonna be really interesting
cuz can he can he hide
I guess he's hiding mmm not what I
wanted
oh wait a minute no he's losing he six
that's good
and then maybe he'll lose more stuff I
can take care of threatening mate oh he
can take though I don't know why I did
that
[Music]
okay this is getting weird
I'm down to pieces but his kings open
and he's law in time
such a messy game
hmm on a play rocket sheet there we go
Oh
Hans
okay very messy game which chess book
would be best for someone to read that
has never read a chest book USDF rating
about 1500 which chess play
mmm has never read a chess book
let me think about that
fifteen hundred
to 1500 with never reading a chess book
I guess just online resources these days
are good enough to get good I mean I'm a
huge fan of Salman to like the Sillman
complete end game course book or
reassess your chess their classic books
probably reassess your chess is such a
good book it's heavy material though
like you have to be dedicated you have
to put the time and effort in why am I
just hanging everything it's hard to
talk and play same time
let's do this trade Queens simplify oh
man that was a good move I'm losing a
piece
but as we've seen before miracles do
happen and all the sunny six can't be
defended and I for Kim okay the switch
to momentum here get the open file mean
me three maybe and invade mmm beep on it
doesn't look too free but I'm hopeful
maybe Queen here no let's not do that
if aid is still covered do this and down
so much time in now Queen here still
doesn't work and tactics are difficult
I just want to attack
wait what's going on here
do I have perpetual
be more than happy to take perpetual
I'm trying to win this probably a bad
decision
whoa activating my inner and routing no
that was not out what I wanted I mind I
just slipped up
that was probably winnable cuz I could
pre move every move that was not my
inner Andrew ting ah so close I just had
to take his pawns okay
now I'm playing like been flying gold
it's probably not a good sign this is
usually what Ben does
didn't didn't he be like mama DRI was
this opening or something something
would happened
high fives a good move night a six was a
bad move
because now my nights are conflicting
not what I wanted entirely play f6 and
g5 okay this is sort of playable little
bit caught claustrophobic but
maybe be fired at some points mm that
hangs up on but it's again bit
bring the knight back attack a3
remembering the night to be four maybe
you
you
hmm
Gupta approach
ting name
no I was so mesmerized by his name I
just hung the Queen
mm at least I have a night for a queen I
don't know if I Knight can do that much
okay that was a weird move what move was
that he feels bad for me or something
let's do stuff with Knights oh he hung a
queen wow he's so generous
when is this
oh wait a minute I'm still I still need
to prove this
you
oh my gosh it's going on such a messy
sequence of moves
you
you
there we go okay
you
is Gupta approach be Feingold
yes sir uh yeah okay I'm in seventh
place I'm playing Alda again have I
played London against him I forget let's
play Oh London
try and make something happen here this
should take up three interesting
looks like a decent position I'm gonna
pawn kind of
currently up upon
mmm he won the pond back
now white is just slightly slightly
worse this book has more center ponds
that's a good move
defend me too he's moving very quickly
to keep up pace
I was a very good move Oh 93 is coming
no he saw it okay
what to do I have to go for counterplay
hmm
interesting
what to do maybe this
he's winning stuff don't play a five he
played that five
hey I'm coming back kind of I don't
think he should have done that and maybe
it's justified but there's hope
not too much hope
you
you
okay good game what did I do wrong
I gave him the pawn back on f4 I should
have been more aware I guess
maybe he just outplayed me
I'm still close to breaking 2500 just a
couple more wins away play a perk
I like Karpov
as a very famous game between Karpov and
teaming Karpov uses set up a lot of
success
main idea is you just keep efore very
well defended
and then black doesn't have really any
other targets supposedly I want to play
f4 here
on storm
interesting maybe I can play this this
is pinned oh that Bishop was defended
though so still not bad
I have my pawn storm
maybe I'll be tricky maybe homeless man
of six now he's seeing it oh he didn't
see it Wow
that's nice thank you for the follow
Houdini appreciate it
okay he's gonna play on I haven't been
looking at followers I don't know how
many follows there have been so far but
thank you everyone who have generously
given their follow to me
in trouble now the e-files opening lots
of pressure hmm where is my killer move
maybe g6 coming
mmm that's scary ooh I just hung a
bishop oh my gosh I just want a queen
that was so bad
Wow and I'm low on time okay I need a
miracle I just hung all my pieces within
a few moves mmm not promising
you
no stop it stop it No
Oh as close
know why I gave him all my pieces like
that are you playing them on Maya
against friends
I don't know if that's quest that
question is directed towards me
um which book to read first probably
reassess your chests pashka we meet
again let's play let's play my main line
you
ishka is also streaming apparently on
YouTube oh okay we'll move did he just
came upon I think he hung up on mean
before I can just castle
which
lots of trades
hmm
this move between 63
from afar
as up upon White has better developments
just as complicated I want to play off64
Bishop e6 and be happy
to put the reckoned yet that's okay
at the d-file the only open file
yes we can trade oh my gosh I just
dropped a rook oh that's so embarrassing
don't beat me please don't beat me
oh he's gonna beat me
mmm any tricks here
oh that was just terrible
happens when you play too much chess
each five notes for you five
good move
- I do how the mate is coming everywhere
what how is that not meat oh where does
like oh that I didn't see King me for
good game pashka well that's sad
I'm ending this tournament in pretty bad
fashion also last three in a row
probably means it's time for a break but
okay one more game is this Maurice
Ashley this might be Maurice Ashley
because he went as black bear on ICC
it's not showing the GM title so maybe
that's just some random person
and I'm just like really bad chest now
such a bad setup maybe I'll survive
you
you
oh he could have taken 95 all these
meeting tricks
slightly more alive here
yeah I'm very alive he has triple pawns
I'll have to win them one by one
start by doubling up he's gonna play
rook c5 or that defend but okay yeah one
by one
Brooksie maybe but I can take
I want all his puns sign up upon here
and as Kings exposed
mm display Queen d7 first
be safe
five running mate in one
and then this
enforcer Queen trade
in the south
this is hard to defend in bullet
as white yeah because now it's just
winning
well I finished with a win
tenth place top ten oh that last game
didn't count
yeah well good games everyone at least I
broke 2400 I started the tournament
below 2400 so as I said before I'm
probably not going to end it right now
wanted to stick around a little bit
after the tournament
well I'm not entirely sure what to do
probably only stick around for like 15
20 minutes if anyone has questions or
you want to play me feel free to send me
a challenge I'll be reading the chats
you see if I missed anything from the
chat never if af6 says Ben Feingold says
John John one three four
yeah hey I'm getting a challenge from ex
villager I'll accept
yeah maybe I'll do like QA
um I like open his study oh my gosh my
microphone I'll make a new study and
I'll just answer people's questions
about openings or whatever yeah Lee
Pollock I would be happy to to play a
match against Finn's
I played Finn's a few days ago in the
titled arena and I beat him I find him
in a losing position it was a fun game
though if I play a match against him it
would probably have to be on Ches comm
if if you were to stream its
but I might have matches coming up I've
been talking with with chest chiller and
also on just talk about something just
have to figure out logistics f3 is
usually not the move to play maybe we
can go over this opening afterwards
because I mean white has options but a
lot of players don't know how to respond
as white it already looks kind of
pheasant d5 and there's targets in the
position B fives a threat
also taking here as a threats
just tough and rest Toth is an
international master from Australia also
does a lot of online content he streams
he has a YouTube channel very
instructive YouTube channel he's one of
the few people who I recommend my
students to watch videos of those videos
are very instructional I just got a
donation that I missed
wait what's and go to Stream labs I
haven't really been looking at the
alerts but I think someone may have just
donated I'm gonna take care
there's going to be major problems along
this diagonal take care
you
oh wow San Diego thank you so much for
$25 um I'm sorry I missed the donation I
don't know how long ago I guess it
happened just a minute ago I do
appreciate it
I also appreciate the free Queen from um
car nut care narf on a ka x villager oh
he muted the stream well I'm very
grateful for both donations
okay
this off
another free pawn way people are being
generous
rook t1
what to do maybe fish up there
passed upon 99 is asking if I'm on
YouTube there should be a youtube
command if someone types in like
exclamation point YouTube I'm pretty
sure a moobot will deliver
not hesitate to contact me chest mines
oh cool
um yeah I'll have to reach out guy only
know to adjust mods maybe I know more
but I just don't know our mods to reach
out to like our ex or no joke or someone
but yeah I have I have my own YouTube
channel and I have videos on the same of
those Chess Club YouTube channel I think
the video is on st. Louis chess club
they're a bit more popular
my videos on YouTube are basically just
archives of my streams at some point out
I will try and make more original
content or more
content geared for YouTube but it just
takes more effort
um okay why this putting up some
resistance I forgot about about my rook
I'm eight
it's just sacrifice the Queen
simplify things
should you just pay attention to time
too do I have any videos on Danish or
elephants I have a video on how to play
against the Danish and Scotch gambit as
black but not for the white side if I do
make more videos it will be on openings
because I do have a lot of material I
saved him over the years
v6 should get the job done
you
Rosen was talented now he's retired I'm
not entirely retired from competitive
chess I have a lot of tournaments coming
up and by a lot I mean two tournaments
coming up in Europe over the summer I
just don't play as often as I used to
play
animals let's do some leather checkmate
good game yeah thank you we should go
over that opening though I mean make uh
I should have the study bookmarked
somewhere
where is my bookmark study
openings
it's probably a dumb thing to type in
openings
answering opening questions here we go
not really an opening question but I
like to show how to play against time on
of there's many decent lines for whites
I'll just give people a few to choose
from mainly Forex villager how we play
against time on earth yeah it's tricky
to play against Sicilians because black
has so many variations and sometimes
white has to respond differently to each
specific variation so it's important to
kind of distinguish between Sicilians
and then know it to play against each
move order so the variation we went into
is tomahto which is a position arriving
or rising after Queen c7 in key played
Bishop e2 played some move order like
this Bishop e2 a six Bishop e3 this is
this is one of the main lines this is
what we call the classical variation
now usually black plays 906
and I think the first mistake from light
was playing f3 this is just it's too
early to play off three there's no
reason to in many cases white likes to
play f4 immediately and not have the
pawn or not three and there's many lines
for example for example after the best
move castling if black plays something
like Bishop e7 or d6 light will go for
the media f4 and it's it's more of a
savannah game where light has attacking
ideas on the kingside
so the main kind of time on of move is a
smooth Bishop to b4 and a lot of players
struggle with this move for a whites
because there's a media pressure and
maybe it's not so clear how white she
respond to the threats and pashka fell
for something like this - I think Pesce
and the bullet tournament allowed taking
and then I won the e4 pawn so the best
move for white here is actually not that
intuitive and it's actually really
important that you just know the move is
it's just a hard move to figure out the
best move is Knight a 4 which might look
very strange at first moves the knight
to the side it leaves this pawn and
defended but if you look a bit closer
there's actually some some deeper ideas
which can be very strong for whites so
the big question here is okay what
happens after a knight a q4 and this is
answered by simple tactics this is
actually just a blunder for black make
some annotations like can very simply
take and then whatever black takes back
with let's say pawn and then there's
Queen d4 and too many things are
attacked the black can almost never take
on e4 in this position
so there's a few different moves for
black here I think the main move and the
move that I like to play is castling
but then if we see the idea of nine a
four it aims to target the the be six
square so white is actually happy to go
after the bishop hair to simply take on
c6 take and then ninety six that's
relatively forcing line after rook b8
and take the bishop take and then take
on eighty six a lot of things get traded
the position transforms white keeps
initiative and the line actually goes
for a bit longer
from this position I think if we turn on
reference in this position these these
three moves are about equally as common
I'm not mistaken yeah all the moves are
playable I usually like to play rook f8
is there some deep lines where you want
f7 defended it's the most common move
and then after Bishop d3 white is
actually temporarily up upon
but black wins it back with this move
Bishop d6 and the line just keeps going
from here
I think White has a bunch of different
moves like could play f4 or g3 or h3 or
even King h1 and I mean if you if you
take your opening seriously you should
really learn the the line much further
out because this is uh it's most likely
line to happen in these these
time-honored variations many cases black
ends up winning the B to pawn for
example let's say white plays g3 the
best move for black is actually to play
Bishop e5 and then white still can't
defend the b2 pollen after c3 or uptake
b2 it's an imbalanced position like both
sides have play so I don't think I'll go
any further from here because like
there's so many things I can branch out
X villager is asking do I like the
position for black or white I mean I've
only played this for black in my opinion
black should equalize in most lines
maybe objectively white is slightly
better but I think theory is still
developing and there's so many options
for for both sides in in some of these
lines that it's hard to make a concise
conclusion but I don't mind playing this
is black it's it's imbalance I probably
wouldn't mind playing this is white with
the two bishops and in some cases this a
pawn could be very strong
so I'll leave it at that
Koshka is 8 years old and he beat me
ouch I feel bad now but he's a good
player he's going to be
very very strong in a few more years
he's already very strong but he's gonna
be even stronger just kind of scary
yeah I'll answer I'll answer other
opening questions if anyone has them
let me scroll up here
um or anyone wants to like see me go
over a certain opening the elephant
gambit was mentioned earlier but I even
know if I know what the elephant gambit
is
what if the whites move the AP on
I don't quite understand by the way
thank you for the follows Sleepy Eye RV
Mars a Brevik who followed half-hour ago
um oh the elephant trap yeah there's an
elephant trap which I could show
um elephant trap
truck
happens
it's just one of these kind of classic
opening tricks and the Queens gambit
declined or black plays this move Knight
pd7 looks like this pawn is hanging
after take take take
so this is a elephant trap wherein I
take d5 is actually a blunder I think
they call it the elephant trap because
the Russian word for elephant is also
the Russian word for Bishop
um Sloane and the trap happens after
Knight takes d5 Bishop take t8 and then
the Sloane comes into b4 and then black
wins the Queen back and it's now just up
a piece for upon
can you do the confer black
I don't actually know too much about the
con I know it's a close relative to the
time on earth but I wouldn't know like
what to show in Kaunas usually like a 6
and a 6 3 6 and a 6 I'm supposed to be a
solid opening started playing petrov you
know any interesting lines in this
opening I could go over one interesting
line in the petrov I think I may have
discussed earlier maybe I haven't
um okay let me show you a funny line in
the Petrov
a new chapter
in mine in the Petrov
interesting for black I think I've shown
this before I've definitely showed the
trap I don't know if I've shown the best
response for whites are you have a just
a funny tidbit from a few days ago I was
playing John Bartholomew who goes by
fins on me chest and the title of arena
and he wasn't streaming but he he posted
his his whole tournament on on YouTube I
think yesterday and I yesterday two days
ago so I watched I watched his
commentary along side my commentary
during our game and I played the petrel
against him and at the exact moment that
I played 906 we both mentioned that
black is playing like Fabiano Caruana
this Fabiano has made this opening very
popular recently especially my
candidates so the line the line that
John played is Knight c3 and then we
just transposed into a four Knights and
it was a very boring opening the line I
was planning to play I was kind of
hoping that he would go into is might
take e5 and I would play Knight a key
for C main sequence with the Fabiano
emotes ie mode is still underused but I
appreciates any presence of Viviano so
anyway this line looks looks pretty dumb
because I like to just play Queen e2 and
if the knight moves anywhere then
there's is oh my gosh I can't draw your
eyes there's a knight c6 which just wins
the Queen
so the point for black this is still
playable but black has to play very
severely here like Queenie seven
essentially copying White's white wins
tonight and then black will win the
night back and this is actually a gambit
line I don't know what we call this I
guess it's called the Damiano variation
or the Col mph gambit okay that's
interesting to know I know there's been
like a few strong players who play this
for black but maybe some success I don't
know idea is that after d4 take take
white slip upon the blackest develop
with with initiative after night c6 and
in many cases if White's not prepared
black can easily equalize and in some
cases black can even get white into some
some dirty traps on so the first time I
ever encountered this I was playing the
white side and I had never seen it
before and I played the most natural
move as white I played Bishop f4 which
is actually already a mistake it runs
into very nasty sequence of moves black
plays g5 I played the ship g3 and my
opponent at the time is like some small
tournament I pong was 1800 and after his
next move he's winning a piece on f5
I was just a shock that I can't take on
the song cuz there's a pain and f4 is
coming now I did manage to somehow come
back and win even though blacks winning
a piece but it's a nice trap I've
trapped many strong players online with
this and it's one of those things that
means still a lot of people just don't
know about
so anyway maybe I'll go ahead and show
the refutation or the so-called
refutation to this we go back
the best the best response for white is
actually sort of surprising I can
actually just give the pawn back by
Knight c3
with idea that okay blocks gonna take
with Queen if I take e five there's
ninety five and it's immediately for
whites after Queen take e5 a best play
for White is Queen take e5 Knight e5 and
Bishop f4 and white is giving back the
pawn but now get some initiative there's
issues for black with ninety five and c7
both being undefended black will usually
play Bishop to e6 natural move
now this is actually a really
instructive moment uh white to move and
play the best move and I would encourage
people who haven't seen this position
before that you actually try and like
think in this position and try and find
the best move but for now I'll just show
it I should know it's that white would
like to play 94 and 95 the problem with
both of these moves is that black can
respond with night d3 or Knight f3 so
for example nike5 9 f3 this is actually
good for black bishops and no more no
more problem C sevens defended so the
very powerful move for white is actually
a very quiet prophylactic move very
simply Bishop g3 and I think this is one
of the reasons this is so instructive is
because Bishop g3 isn't the type of move
you would think would be so powerful but
it's simply preventing against any 93 or
or Knight f3 ideas and black can't stop
both of these threats black could play
like a six but 994 is coming and what's
gonna happen is White's gonna get the
bishop hair in just just a better
position either bishop pair or better
like Khan structure both like for
example
I'll say Bishop a five-night here
I'd rip t8 taketake it's just a better
position for lights and all these lines
so anyway something useful to know it's
gray plaits opening for black but as
white if you play e4 you probably want
to at least know this line know through
these know it through Bishop g3 so
someone was saying castling goslings
navigate a great move after Bishop d6
because there's still 93 and black would
be doing very fine here
against d4 how do you like to play the
budapest gambit against opponent that
knows a smothered maid trap
[Music]
depends what light does I know what Lyon
san diego's talking about
ah
Budapest it really depends what light
does if the opponent knows this mother
made chopped there's a myriad of things
white can do
for those of you who have no idea what
we're referring to Budapest smothered
mate trap this is another like great
simple opening especially if you're
looking for something against d4 but I
can play e5 Budapest gambit
play Bishop f4 black wants to win the
pawn back 92 white plays a3
then black ticks on pics on e5f white
takes here this is a smother in a trap I
think a lot of people are following
falling into this before we test
database go back a move
sex
ouch there's been close to 800 games
where black has a 93 mate that's gotta
hurt and then I'm sure there's a sign
too
over 50 games with 19 three mates anyway
I can't take the bishop
if white avoids it's uh like can play
after it take Y can take here but then
you can even take back the bishop still
can't be taken because ninety three
ideas and then if white takes here it's
important to take on d2 and then this is
actually slightly better for black
sequel material but black has easier
development center castles more quickly
so yeah I mean there's a number of
better lines white can play in this 92
line
I see threes a move
this is another line to know for black
where I think it's best to play Queen e7
and then there's some long name line
after Queen d5 I think I've shown this
in the st. Louis Chess Club video we can
take on c3 and then play Queen a3 idea
is if the Queen drops back to D 2 then
we have Queen a5 and black scoops up
this pawn
and I meanwhile if rook c1 which is
maybe the best move and black can play
f6 then it's a true gambits black is
down upon but there's some condensation
open a file add pawn structure for
whites
so yeah Jessie hf2 I think Knight c3 is
better 92 if white is well-prepared but
it's a game nonetheless
should update my stream title maybe I've
scared people away from might be
thinking I'm playing bullets my plan is
to do maybe more instructive streams
like this where it's just purely
dedicated to going over openings I know
that's a topic that a lot of people want
to see or playing like specific openings
or whatever for now I think I'm gonna
end
most things maybe I'll try and answer it
one more question
you play the London and get risking
Xindian c5 line what does the kingdom
mean c5 line
London verse k ID
I actually don't play a true London
against Kings Indian I get true London
would be III I like to play the Barry
attack which is Knight c3 and then if
they play Bishop d7 like to transpose to
a perk
and I guess black could play it still
play c5 in certain positions and then it
can go into a benoni
but I like to just avoid any any like
classic kings Indian black could still
play d6 but then there's these lines
where white castles Queen side early and
goes for Bishop h6 so the Jo bhava
attack yeah I guess to bother me this
popular now I guess it's it should be
noted that c5 is a move here
I've ran into this before probably look
this up maybe d5 is still still a good
response or even take
probably do more up there yeah this is
called the berry attack after Knight c3
you
I did the video for st. Louis chess club
on this line it's just showing games in
this and then they never uploaded the
video so still have to figure out what
happened to this I will say there's a
very good game between grief shook and
some other GN whose name I can't
pronounce
after d5 maybe it's one of the top games
mm you see masters
see if I can find it uh III
each six was played yeah Greece shook
loose new T dunno or whatever his name
is and insert this it's a great game
make it the main line
this is a public study - I'll go ahead
and share it in the Czech as people want
to look over the lines or clone it and
add your own analysis
uh but yeah I think I'm gonna take off
thanks guys for watching I'll be back in
the future probably sometime later this
week but for now have a good day and
maybe I can find someone to raid
so oh wow a lot of people watching Oh
Chris 64 is streaming let's raid crew 64
you 64
he just starts up time
oh he's streaming with cheeky chess
for 25 minutes while okay we are going
to raid crew 64 and turn the volume up
raid through 64